If we only stick to random access, then we are leaving some algorithmic insight on the table because we're not genericizing the algorithms beyond what's in front of us. Welcome to ADSP the Podcast, episode 2299 recorded on April 9th, 2025. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Ben, we chat about an unnamed algorithm, potentially multi-transform or for each but last and more. How have you been? Yeah, are we are we hopping into things and then we'll the topics will come up as they come up?
如果我们只局限于随机访问，那么我们就放弃了一些算法洞察力，因为我们没有将算法泛化到我们眼前的需求之外。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，这是 2025 年 4 月 9 日录制的第 2299 期节目。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Ben 将聊聊一个未命名的算法，可能是 multi-transform（多重转换）或 for each but last（除最后一个外遍历）等等。你最近怎么样？我们要直接进入正题，然后话题会随之展开吗？
Well, I have some questions. I have some potential topics that I've, you know, I made a short list of questions for you a while ago or topics that we could talk about less more so than questions. I think the questions have been answered from our previous talks, but did you have something? Not really anything lined up. When you said you'll bring some short topics, I figured we would just pick from those. I mean, if we run out of stuff to talk about,
嗯，我有一些问题。我有一些潜在的话题，你知道，我前段时间为你列了一个简短的问题清单，或者说我们可以讨论的话题，而不是问题。我觉得之前谈话中那些问题已经得到解答了，但你有什么想说的吗？其实没什么特别准备的。你说你会带一些简短的话题，我想我们就从那些里面选吧。我是说，如果我们没话可聊了的话，
I do have some stuff we can talk about. I mean, but I doubt that we will run out of stuff. But anyways, yes, we can start with how have you been but I doubt that we will run out of stuff. But anyways, yes, we can start with how have you been? I've been good. How about you? Good. Yeah, pretty good. We had a fake spring here in Denver and then it turned cold again. So I turned my sprinklers on and then I had to turn them off again last week. But they're back on now. It's going to be warm again. Spring weather this week. Um, last week, but they're back on now. It's going to be warm again. Spring weather this week.
我确实有一些可以聊的东西。我是说，但我怀疑我们不会没话可聊。但无论如何，是的，我们可以从“你最近怎么样”开始，但我怀疑我们不会没话可聊。但无论如何，是的，我们可以从“你最近怎么样”开始？我一直很好。你呢？很好。是的，相当不错。我们在丹佛经历了一个假春天，然后天气又变冷了。所以我打开了喷灌系统，上周又不得不关掉。但现在它们又开了。天气又要变暖了。这周是春天的天气。嗯，上周，但现在它们又开了。这周是春天的天气。
Wow. How long did the, um, the winter rematerialize for? Well, it didn't get super cold. Um, it was about a week of like cloudy days and freezing nights. I mean, it got down to minus five, minus six Celsius. Wow. Which is not real cold, but it's cold enough that it's cold enough. It's cold enough. Yeah You're not wearing shorts outside. There was a one night I mean it's it's below zero in Celsius right now and in Toronto But it was really nice for like a week or two. So it's kind of similar but it it For one night overnight, I guess it was blizzarding for like it started at like 2 p.m There was no snow on the ground.
哇。冬天又重现了多久？嗯，没有变得特别冷。嗯，大约有一周的时间是阴天和冰冻的夜晚。我是说，气温降到了零下五六摄氏度。哇。这不算真正的冷，但冷到足以……冷到足以。冷到足以。是的，你在外面不能穿短裤。有一天晚上，我是说，多伦多现在的气温在零摄氏度以下。但有一两周天气真的很好。所以有点类似，但是……有一天晚上，我想是下暴风雪了，大约从下午 2 点开始。地上一点雪都没有。
A couple days before it had been above zero Celsius. And then started blizzarding, dropped to minus five, but then popped up above freezing for the evening. So then it just turned into this slush, freezing cold nightmare. And then the next day, by 4 p.m. in the afternoon, 3 p.m. in the afternoon, it was 18 degrees Celsius, which I don't know if that is in Fahrenheit, but it's like shorts weather and t-shirt weather.
几天前气温还在零摄氏度以上。然后开始下暴风雪，降到零下五度，但晚上又回升到了冰点以上。所以它就变成了一场泥泞、冰冷的噩梦。然后第二天，到了下午 4 点，下午 3 点，气温是 18 摄氏度，我不知道这相当于华氏多少度，但就像是穿短裤和 T 恤的天气。
That's the 60s. Yeah. And all the snow had disappeared and there was a bunch of parks that just had like flooded with because you know, you got all this precipitation and then anyways, it's just like one second it's nice, the next second it's blizzarding the next second. It's freezing rain anyways enough about weather Yeah, it's nice here in Denver today. It's like Sunny and 22 degrees or something at the Celsius ice this spring Celsius. Yeah. Yeah, that is back back to spring Whether it will be a another fake spring who can tell
那是华氏 60 多度。是的。所有的雪都消失了，很多公园都被淹了，因为你知道，降水太多了，总之，就是一秒钟天气很好，下一秒钟就下暴风雪，再下一秒钟就是冻雨。总之，关于天气就说这么多吧。是的，丹佛今天天气很好。阳光明媚，气温 22 摄氏度左右，这个春天。摄氏度。是的。是的，又回到了春天。这会不会又是另一个假春天，谁知道呢？
Yeah, I mean fingers crossed. We're recording this April 9th and this will be coming out over the rest of April probably. Okay. Hopefully this is going to be springtime, no more snow, but you know, time will tell. Anyways. So I have been thinking recently about an algorithm that I actually asked you and Tristan about a while back. Yes. Which is, well, there are a couple of algorithms. Actually, I'm surprised we don't already have
是的，我是说祈祷吧。我们是在 4 月 9 日录制的，这期节目可能会在 4 月剩下的时间里发布。好的。希望这就是春天了，不再有雪，但你知道，时间会证明一切。总之。所以我最近一直在思考一个算法，我前段时间其实问过你和 Tristan。是的。也就是，嗯，有几个算法。其实我很惊讶我们还没有
them in the standard and not even I've looked they're not in boost algorithms. They're not in ASL Adobe source library. Adobe's, yeah. Yeah. But one of the patterns I had noticed, because I work in embedded now, one of the patterns I'd noticed in interfacing with hardware is that sometimes you have a range, you have an array, let's say, of integers or integral types. The first one of those you write to one register, then the body of them you count as data that
在标准库里看到它们，甚至我查过，它们不在 Boost 算法库里。它们也不在 ASL（Adobe 源代码库）里。Adobe 的，是的。是的。但我注意到的模式之一，因为我现在从事嵌入式开发，我在与硬件交互时注意到的模式之一是，有时你有一个范围，比方说一个整数或整型数组。你将其中第一个写入一个寄存器，然后将中间的部分作为数据计数，
you write to a different register and then the last one you do something else again. Maybe writing back to the first register, maybe writing to a different register, but there's this idea of like you're trisecting the data, you're doing an initial thing and a final thing and in between you're doing a medial thing for all of the elements. And so this would be nice to have an algorithm to do that and that was what I originally asked you and Tristan about. It struck me that a building block algorithm for that, because it's quite easy, it's trivial to take off the head of a sequence, right? But it's less trivial to do all but one or all
写入另一个寄存器，然后最后一个你再做点别的。也许是写回第一个寄存器，也许是写到不同的寄存器，但这里有一个想法，就是你把数据三等分，你做了一个初始操作和一个最终操作，而在中间你对所有元素做了一个中间操作。所以如果有一个算法能做到这一点会很好，这就是我最初问你和 Tristan 的问题。我突然想到，一个用于此的构建块算法，因为这很简单，去掉序列的头部是微不足道的，对吧？但去掉除一个以外的所有元素，或者去掉
but n of the sequence, right? So you do something. So for everything in the sequence except the last one, right? So you stop at the last one. And that's kind of the building block algorithm, an algorithm we might call for each but last or for each but last n perhaps. And what brought me to mind, what brought this algorithm to mind for me was this this is an algorithm in common Lisp and it's called but last. But it's not an algorithm in C++ that I've ever seen anyone use. When you say but last, that's minus the transformation, right? That's just the destructuring of.
序列的 n 个元素以外的所有元素，就没那么简单了，对吧？所以你做某事。所以对于序列中除最后一个以外的所有元素，对吧？所以你在最后一个停下。这就是那种构建块算法，一个我们可能称之为 for each but last 或 for each but last n 的算法。让我想到这个算法的原因是，这是 Common Lisp 中的一个算法，叫做 but last。但在 C++ 中，我从未见过有人使用它。当你提到 but last 时，那是减法转换，对吧？那只是解构。
Yeah, it's common list calls it but last. You can think of it as like for each but last. Right. Actually, actually in common list, in common list, but it just returns a list minus the last element. Right, right. I mean, Haskell does have this as well.
是的，Common Lisp 称之为 but last。你可以把它看作是 for each but last。对吧。其实，在 Common Lisp 中，but last 只是返回一个减去最后一个元素的列表。对吧，对吧。我是说，Haskell 也有这个。
Okay. There's four of them, right? There's head, tail, knit, and last, I think. And so I think a knit is the one that is the n minus one first elements. Okay, okay. But yeah, now you mentioned it, that does ring a bell. There is, I'm sure, a way to do this in Haskell. So the question in C++ is how we would do this. Would we do it? It seems natural to have for each but last, for each but last end. These seem like natural interfaces, at least, that we can think about.
好的。有四个，对吧？我想是 head、tail、init 和 last。所以我认为 init 就是除最后一个元素以外的所有元素。好的，好的。但确实，现在你提到了，这听起来很耳熟。我相信在 Haskell 中肯定有办法做到这一点。所以 C++ 中的问题是我们该如何实现它。我们会这样做吗？拥有 for each but last，for each but last n 似乎很自然。至少我们可以想到这些自然的接口。
Would it be appropriate to do this? I mean, we could do this by like a reverse, a take, a reverse, a drop and a reverse or something, you know, in ranges. Or we could just do the old style to iterator algorithm, right? And it's sort of trivial for random axis iterators. It is less trivial for bidirectional iterators, and it's less trivial yet for forward iterators. Right. I mean, and so we're just talking
这样做合适吗？我是说，我们可以通过 reverse、take、reverse、drop 和 reverse 之类的方法来实现，你知道，在 ranges 中。或者我们可以直接使用旧式的双迭代器算法，对吧？对于随机访问迭代器来说，这有点微不足道。对于双向迭代器来说，它没那么简单，而对于前向迭代器来说，它就更不简单了。对吧。我是说，我们只是在谈论
about the simplified version. We're not talking about first, middle, and last. We're just talking about. No, I'm just talking about, for the moment that the last algorithm. Yeah I mean my first thought which is odd because I didn't have this thought when you asked Tristan and I via email. Was you asked us like what would you call this kind of algorithm and I think if my memory serves correctly I said something like multi transform. Yeah that was for the. The high level algorithm I think I was asking about, yeah, the three-pronged one.
简化版本。我们不是在谈论 first、middle 和 last。我们只是在谈论。不，我只是在谈论，目前那个 last 算法。是的，我的第一个想法，这很奇怪，因为当你和 Tristan 通过电子邮件问我时，我没有这个想法。你问我们“你会把这种算法称为什么”，如果我没记错的话，我说的是类似 multi-transform（多重转换）。是的，那是针对那个。我想我问的是那个高层算法，是的，那个三叉的。
Yeah. And I don't think that's a great name, but it does capture the essence of like, if you want to talk about the three partitioned one, it is kind of a transform that's bundled with three different unary operations that's being applied to three different segments. And my thought that I had just now is, is it useful to kind of genericize, or like, I don't know, abstract it a level higher and not necessarily have the first and the last, but just like three different segments? So it's like similar to the rotate API that has three iterators.
是的。我不认为这是一个好名字，但它确实抓住了本质，如果你想谈论那个三部分划分的算法，它确实是一种捆绑了三个不同一元操作的转换，分别应用于三个不同的段。我刚才的想法是，将其泛化，或者说抽象到一个更高的层次，不一定非要是第一个和最后一个，而只是三个不同的段，这样有用吗？所以它类似于具有三个迭代器的 rotate API。
You could give this one four iterators. That is the begin, start of medial, start of final and end. And that would suit your need. And then also it would, the reason that I had this thought now, and I'm not sure why I had it earlier, maybe it was the problem was phrased, I don't know, sometimes your brain has different thoughts, is that multi-transform then becomes a better name, because it's not specifically this pattern where it's like the first, last, and then the middle chunk.
你可以给这个算法四个迭代器。即 begin、medial 的开始、final 的开始和 end。这就能满足你的需求。而且，我之所以现在有这个想法，我不确定为什么之前没有，也许是因为问题表述的方式，我不知道，有时你的大脑会有不同的想法，是因为 multi-transform 变成了一个更好的名字，因为它不是专门针对这种“第一个、最后一个，然后是中间块”的模式。
There's no real, like what are you going to call that tail, middle head transform? Like that's a terrible name, right? But that closely matches the semantics of what you're transforming. Whereas multi-transform, if you have like variable length segments, it then matches that. But then my question to you is, because you're the one that actually has the use case, is
对于那种“尾部、中间、头部”的转换，真的没有一个好的称呼，对吧？那是一个糟糕的名字，对吧？但这与你正在转换的语义非常吻合。而 multi-transform，如果你有可变长度的段，它就匹配了。但我的问题是，因为你是那个真正有使用场景的人，
that, does that make the usefulness of it just like more confusing? Like, really, all you want is that first, last, and middle one, and you'd never have a use case for the variable length segments ones. Well, there are a couple of things to say. first, last, and middle one and you'd never have a use case for the variable length segments ones. Well, there are a couple of things to say. I think yes, the use case I have is the... I've been calling them initial, medial, and final to try to find a better name because first and last tend to be used by iterators and begin and end also mean other things.
这会让它的实用性变得更令人困惑吗？真的，你想要的只是那个第一个、最后一个和中间的一个，而你永远不会有可变长度段的使用场景？嗯，有几件事要说。第一个、最后一个和中间的一个，而你永远不会有可变长度段的使用场景。嗯，有几件事要说。我想是的，我有的使用场景是……我一直称它们为 initial（初始）、medial（中间）和 final（最终），试图找到一个更好的名字，因为 first 和 last 往往被迭代器使用，而 begin 和 end 也意味着其他东西。
So at the moment, I've settled on initial, medial, final as the designators. But yes, the use case I have is first one, last one and medial ones. And the use case I have right now involves only arrays, so random access. So it's fairly simple. If it becomes multi-transformed, the question sort of becomes, how do you compute those inner iterators? Because ideally, you want to be able to express. There is definitely an expression there of, I want to do everything, something for everything
所以目前，我确定使用 initial、medial、final 作为指示符。但是的，我有的使用场景是第一个、最后一个和中间的那些。而且我现在的使用场景只涉及数组，也就是随机访问。所以它相当简单。如果它变成了 multi-transform，问题就变成了，你如何计算那些内部迭代器？因为理想情况下，你希望能够表达。那里肯定有一种表达方式，即我想对除最后一个以外的所有元素做某事，
but the last, or this idea of initial, medial and final, right? Without knowing how long the range is, how long the range is without caring whether it's a by die range or a random access range or even a forward range. The caller doesn't want to, the caller wants to specify, the caller doesn't want to compute the intermediate iterators is what I'm saying. Because if you can do that, then you can just trivially split it into three ranges and call transform three times. Right? That the idea of this algorithm is that you can say, I want to do the last n, the first n this way, the last n another way, and the intermediate ones a third way.
或者这种 initial、medial 和 final 的想法，对吧？在不知道范围有多长的情况下，在不关心它是双向范围、随机访问范围还是前向范围的情况下。调用者不想，调用者想要指定，调用者不想计算中间迭代器，这就是我想说的。因为如果你能做到这一点，那么你就可以简单地把它分成三个范围并调用三次 transform，对吧？这个算法的想法是，你可以说，我想以这种方式处理最后 n 个，以另一种方式处理前 n 个，以第三种方式处理中间的那些。
But like, I don't want to have to compute, the computation of that iterator, which is the start of the last n, and n being one in my case, right? I don't want to have to do that outside the algorithm. Wait, so I got a little bit confused there because when you said, if you are able to compute the iterators,
但是，我不希望必须计算，那个迭代器的计算，也就是最后 n 个的开始，在我的例子中 n 是 1，对吧？我不希望必须在算法之外做这件事。等等，所以我有点困惑，因为当你提到，如果你能够计算迭代器，
you can just call three separate transforms. I thought this was effectively an algorithm that you can just call once instead of doing that. So there's some difference here and then you said you don't know the end so that like there's you want to be able to possibly use this when you don't know the length of your array or something like that? Well yeah I mean these are situations we can think about like if you had an iterator in a sentinel and it was only a forward range, right? Right. These are potential use cases in the general case.
你就可以直接调用三个单独的 transform。我以为这实际上是一个你可以只调用一次而不是那样做的算法。所以这里有一些区别，然后你说你不知道 end，所以你想要能够在不知道数组长度的情况下使用它？嗯，是的，我是说这些是我们能想到的情况，比如如果你有一个迭代器和一个哨兵，而且它只是一个前向范围，对吧？对。这些是通用情况下的潜在使用场景。
And then in that situation, my multi-transform with variable length segments isn't possible because you can't like know elements from the end. It's only in the case where you're at the sentinel now so you now know. Interesting. OK, so that's slightly different than what I was thinking about. Yeah. Multi-transform. If you can easily compute the iterate, the start and end iterators for each transform, then we have effectively, you just call three transform three times. But this is for the case where those are not easily computable. But you know
然后在那种情况下，我的带有可变长度段的 multi-transform 是不可能的，因为你不能像知道末尾的元素那样。只有当你现在处于哨兵位置时，你才知道。有趣。好的，所以这和我刚才想的略有不同。是的。Multi-transform。如果你能轻松计算每个 transform 的开始和结束迭代器，那么我们实际上就是调用了三次 transform。但这适用于那些不容易计算的情况。但你知道
how many you want to do at the beginning and how many you want to do at the end. Wait, so can you do it when you know how many you want to do at the end where n is greater than one? Is that possible? It's possible. At the moment, I'm still exploring this kind of design space and thinking about how we might do it, right? You can go backwards or you can see you know, how many steps it would take you to reach the end, you know, right? Right. I'm think I'm thinking of just like single pass You apply your first stop then your second on my third op
你在开头想处理多少个，在结尾想处理多少个。等等，当 n 大于 1 时，你知道你想在结尾处理多少个，你能做到吗？这是可能的。目前，我仍在探索这种设计空间，思考我们该如何做，对吧？你可以向后走，或者你可以看到，你知道，你需要多少步才能到达终点，你知道，对吧？对。我正在考虑就像单次遍历，你应用你的第一个操作，然后是第二个，然后是第三个操作。
Which now doesn't work in this like you'd have to determine where the end is and then yeah I'm potentially like do the start, do it reverse from the back, and then go do the middle section last. You don't need to do it that way, but that could be a potential. Potentially. In my use case, there is an ordering that the,
这在现在这种情况下行不通，你必须确定终点在哪里，然后，是的，我可能像做开始，从后面反向做，然后最后做中间部分。你不需要那样做，但这可能是一个潜在的方法。潜在地。在我的使用场景中，有一个顺序，即
yeah, you have to do initial, then medial, then final. But so it's not three independent transforms. I see, yeah. But it's something like find last. You know, we have find last now in C++ and I believe it was Zach who worked a bunch on that. And you have to basically involves iterating to the end because you need to only by iterating the end can you tell that you've found the last thing, right? And there's something similar going on here in this last algorithm or the initial, media final, you know, higher level version, which is we need to even in a forward range, we need to iterate to the end in order to know how far away from the end we are for those last for those last
是的，你必须先做 initial，然后是 medial，然后是 final。所以这不是三个独立的 transform。我明白了，是的。但这有点像 find last。你知道，我们现在在 C++ 中有 find last，我相信是 Zach 在那方面做了很多工作。你基本上需要遍历到末尾，因为你只有通过遍历到末尾才能知道你找到了最后一个东西，对吧？在这个 last 算法或 initial、medial、final（更高层版本）中也有类似的情况，即我们需要，即使是在前向范围中，我们也需要遍历到末尾，以便知道我们距离末尾有多远，对于那些最后，对于那些最后
for that last set. Yeah, this is interesting. There is more to it than meets the eye at first glance. For sure. Yeah, I totally misunderstood the subtlety of what you were asking for in the initial email. And I think I simplified the problem into I just want a nicer way to spell three transforms, which is not what you're looking for. Right. If you can just spell those, spell those is what is what you're saying. Yeah.
对于那最后一组。是的，这很有趣。它比乍看之下要复杂得多。确实。是的，我完全误解了你在最初的电子邮件中要求的微妙之处。而且我认为我把问题简化成了“我只是想要一种更优雅的方式来拼写三个 transform”，这并不是你想要的。对。如果你能拼写出那些，拼写出那些就是你所说的。是的。
And my current use case, I can just spell them because I'm only using random access. Exactly. And it's fine. And this algorithm is, you know, even then I would like to have the abstraction power of an algorithm, right? So I might like to say do initial, medial, final, but it's not terribly difficult to write that algorithm with random access iterators, right? At the moment, the code is full of raw loops which implement exactly that algorithm, so it's just a case of abstracting that a little bit. It's interesting too because I've been spending a lot more time thinking about iterators, because I finished, or we finished I should say,
而在我目前的使用场景中，我可以拼写它们，因为我只使用随机访问。完全正确。而且没问题。而且这个算法，你知道，即使那样，我也想拥有算法的抽象能力，对吧？所以我可能想说做 initial、medial、final，但用随机访问迭代器编写那个算法并不太难，对吧？目前，代码中充满了实现该算法的原始循环，所以这只是将其稍微抽象一下的问题。这也很有趣，因为我花了很多时间思考迭代器，因为我完成了，或者我们完成了，我应该说，
because we were doing it as the virtual meetup, the from mathematics to generic programming. And I think it's chapter 10 called fundamental programming concepts, where he talks about iterator category, tag dispatch. And I had never, you know, I mean, you know that that's a thing if you program, well, maybe, maybe not everybody knows that's a thing, but most folks that have spent any time studying C++ know that that's a thing, but it wasn't really until
因为我们是作为虚拟聚会来做的，从数学到通用编程。我想是第 10 章，叫做基本编程概念，他在那里谈到了迭代器类别、标签分派。我从来没有，你知道，我是说，你知道如果你编程，那是一回事，好吧，也许，也许不是每个人都知道那是一回事，但大多数花时间研究 C++ 的人都知道那是一回事，但直到
our conversation with Sean, parent, and I should also say for our new ADSP listener, Zach is a previous guest, Zach Lane, who's a member of the ISO committee and has worked on algorithms and does he work on, I think he works on Unicode. Boost text. I think he recently worked a bunch on Unicode with boost text. Yeah. And yes, we had our couple podcast recordings with Sean back in October and we're talking about the different rotate algorithms, the three different rotate algorithms, link in the description. We're not really having that conversation. But I read somewhere that Stepanov,
我们与 Sean Parent 的谈话，我还要为我们新的 ADSP 听众说一下，Zach 是之前的嘉宾，Zach Laine，他是 ISO 委员会的成员，从事算法工作，他是否从事，我想他从事 Unicode。Boost Text。我想他最近在 Boost Text 上做了很多关于 Unicode 的工作。是的，我们在十月份和 Sean 录了几期播客，我们谈论了不同的 rotate 算法，三种不同的 rotate 算法，描述中有链接。我们并不是真的在进行那次谈话。但我读到 Stepanov 在某处，
I think it might've been in this article that he had with some online website after from mathematics to generic programming, or maybe it was EOP. And he said that he had over-emphasized the importance of like the bidirectional and forward iterators that typically are mapped to the linked list and doubly linked lists and things like that. And I've been kind of thinking about,
我想可能是在他从数学到通用编程之后在某个在线网站上发表的文章中，或者可能是 EOP。他说他过分强调了双向和前向迭代器的重要性，这些迭代器通常映射到链表和双向链表等。我一直在思考，
how does this fit into an array language? Because really, I think that array languages, for the most part, we just assume random access. It's in the name, I suppose. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. And that makes, what is the importance of these? This kind of iterator abstraction.
这如何适应数组语言？因为真的，我认为数组语言在很大程度上，我们只是假设随机访问。我想名字里就有。是的。是的，是的。这使得，这些的重要性是什么？这种迭代器抽象。
And there's also some really interesting comments. I'm not sure if you picked up on this or if you recall from having gone through all the lectures back in the day. But he he has like beef, basically, with Andre Alex and dress goo, because I think he gave a talk back in 2009 called iterators must go. And then he said that he completely disagreed with that.
还有一些非常有趣的评论。我不确定你是否注意到了，或者你是否记得当年听过所有的讲座。但他基本上对 Andrei Alexandrescu 有意见，因为我想他在 2009 年做了一个演讲，叫做“迭代器必须消失”。然后他说他完全不同意这一点。
It's this idea of right now you have an algorithm that kind of works for random access. And it's like, how important is it that for C++, I guess, that we have this ability to abstract over different iterator types? And what do you lose in an array language where you just assume random access for everything, basically?? Well I think it's really important it's not necessarily important you know from ultimately from an efficiency point of
这就是现在的想法，你有一个算法，它对随机访问有效。而且就像，对于 C++ 来说，我们拥有这种在不同迭代器类型上进行抽象的能力有多重要？而在你假设一切基本上都是随机访问的数组语言中，你会失去什么？嗯，我认为这非常重要，它不一定重要，你知道，从最终的效率角度来看，
view because most of the time we do want to use array we do want to use vector we want to use at least on desktop we want to use the cache efficiently, right? Now, most of the process in the world don't have caches, but most of the ones we talk about at conferences do. But it's important to go through this exercise beyond random iterators, I think, to gain insight into what the algorithm's true nature is. You know, and Stepanov's original idea, I think, was this forward, by-die, and random,
因为大多数时候我们确实想使用数组，我们确实想使用 vector，我们想使用，至少在桌面上，我们想有效地使用缓存，对吧？现在，世界上大多数处理器都没有缓存，但我们会议上谈论的大多数处理器都有。但我认为，超越随机迭代器进行这种练习很重要，以获得对算法本质的洞察。你知道，Stepanov 最初的想法，我认为，是前向、双向和随机，
right? And then he realized that input iterators exist, right? So in other words, there's a class of forward iterators where you can only traverse the sequence once. And so we have basically the three categories plus the input iterators, a bit strange in some ways, but it's important to genericize the algorithms, right? If we only stick to random access,
对吧？然后他意识到输入迭代器存在，对吧？换句话说，有一类前向迭代器，你只能遍历序列一次。所以我们基本上有三个类别加上输入迭代器，在某些方面有点奇怪，但泛化算法很重要，对吧？如果我们只局限于随机访问，
then we are leaving some algorithmic insight on the table because we're not genericizing the algorithms beyond what's in front of us. There's also the fact of course that we can learn from not just C++ or array languages, but you know the original Lisp, right? Lisp has lists and they are essentially forward iteration. Yeah, that makes sense It leaves some algorithmic insight on the table Yeah, it's it's a shame that Stepanov is kind of retired and he's retired a long time ago But I would love to get his thoughts on like the state of the world today Including like Tristan's work, right? Like Tristan's given a number of talks. Yeah iteration revisited and still all of the API's we have today
那么我们就在放弃一些算法洞察力，因为我们没有将算法泛化到我们眼前的需求之外。当然，还有一个事实是，我们可以学习的不仅仅是 C++ 或数组语言，还有，你知道，最初的 Lisp，对吧？Lisp 有列表，它们本质上是前向迭代。是的，这很有道理。它放弃了一些算法洞察力。是的，Stepanov 退休了，这很遗憾，他很久以前就退休了。但我很想听听他对当今世界状态的看法，包括 Tristan 的工作，对吧？比如 Tristan 发表了许多演讲。是的，迭代重访，而且今天我们拥有的所有 API
You know because they live in C++ provide API's that you know give you begin and end and I think there's some story to that Eric Niebler, you know individual former guest as well on the podcast Behind range v3 and what's in the standard? I think at one point was kind of moving away from iterators, but then he talked to Sean and Sean basically like convinced him that like, you still need this. I thought you were gonna say like Sean hit him upside the head and made him realize the error of his ways.
你知道，因为它们存在于 C++ 中，提供了给你 begin 和 end 的 API，我想这背后有一些故事。Eric Niebler，你知道，也是播客的前嘉宾，Range v3 的幕后推手，标准库里有什么？我想在某个时候有点偏离迭代器，但他和 Sean 谈过，Sean 基本上说服了他，就像，你仍然需要这个。我以为你会说 Sean 敲了他的头，让他意识到自己错了。
Well, I don't know, maybe that is the story. We'll have to get Sean back on and maybe we'll get Eric on at the same time. And we can also, maybe this is the story. We'll have to get Sean back on, and maybe we'll get Eric on at the same time. And we can, also, maybe this story is apocryphal. I don't know who I, I feel like I heard it from Sean. But anyways, it's just because I went through FM2GP, and now have been thinking about this a lot more.
嗯，我不知道，也许这就是故事。我们得把 Sean 请回来，也许我们同时把 Eric 请来。我们也可以，也许这是故事。我们得把 Sean 请回来，也许我们同时把 Eric 请来。我们可以，也，也许这个故事是杜撰的。我不知道，我觉得我是从 Sean 那里听到的。但无论如何，这只是因为我读了 FM2GP，现在对这个问题思考得更多了。
And also, how does this apply to languages like Rust? Rust have traits now, which is superficially different in many ways, but superficially at some level the same thing as concepts now. And I assume, actually, I haven't looked at the standard implementations of C++20 algorithms and on, but I assume that those don't use iterator category TIG dispatch anymore.
而且，这如何应用于像 Rust 这样的语言？Rust 现在有 trait，在很多方面表面上不同，但在某种程度上和现在的概念（concepts）是一样的。而且我假设，其实我没有看过 C++20 及以后算法的标准实现，但我假设那些不再使用迭代器类别标签分派了。
They now use, that's the whole pitch that Stepanov is making is that, you know, we don't have a way to do this kind of dispatch, but like luckily I can just create like a version of these functions that the last parameter is a tag and I can basically dispatch on that. And like behind the scenes, that's what's happening.
它们现在使用，这就是 Stepanov 提出的全部论点，即，你知道，我们没有办法做这种分派，但幸运的是，我可以创建这些函数的版本，最后一个参数是一个标签，我可以基本上根据它进行分派。而且在幕后，这就是正在发生的事情。
But really I would like a language feature that would give me the ability to do that and concepts. Oh, so you mean, yeah. So tag this batch in this view was a hack to achieve what concepts can achieve better. Exactly. And he said as much and then went on to say that like, it's a good hack because at least the language lets me do it.
但实际上我想要一个语言特性，能让我有能力做到这一点，那就是概念。哦，所以你的意思是，是的。所以在这个观点中，标签分派是一个黑客手段，用来实现概念能更好地实现的东西。完全正确。而且他也是这么说的，然后继续说，这是一个很好的黑客手段，因为至少语言让我可以这样做。
There are many languages where I have to do this at runtime. Whereas at least in C++, this all melts away. Right. Sure, it maybe adds a bit of compile time, but at least in terms from an efficiency runtime point of view, I'm not losing anything here. But in certain languages, not only do I not have a language facility, but I don't have anything that gives me the ability to do compile time dispatch based on the quote the right quote-unquote iterator type? Well yes first of all I agree but but I wouldn't be I haven't looked at the implementations in MSSTL or any of the other standard libraries but I wouldn't be too quick to assume that they've written in terms of concepts I I would
有很多语言我必须在运行时做这件事。而在 C++ 中，这一切都融化了。对。当然，它可能增加了一点编译时间，但至少在效率运行时方面，我在这里没有失去任何东西。但在某些语言中，我不仅没有语言设施，而且我没有任何东西能让我有能力基于所谓的“迭代器类型”进行编译时分派？嗯，是的，首先我同意，但我不会，我没有看过 MSSTL 或任何其他标准库中的实现，但我不会太快假设它们是用概念编写的，我
imagine that they you know are still of concepts. I would imagine that they are still using a tag dispatch here and there maybe. Things did change a bit, I think, from 17 to 20 in terms of the way iterators are specified, certainly. But at the end of the day, if you have one compile time way to choose versus another, then I don't know that you'd go rewriting everything in terms of the quote unquote better way if the cogen was identical. You know, it's sort of,
想象它们，你知道，可能仍然在这里或那里使用标签分派。我认为，从 17 到 20，在迭代器的指定方式上确实发生了一些变化。但归根结底，如果你有一种编译时选择方式与另一种相比，那么我不知道如果代码生成是相同的，你是否会重写所有内容以使用所谓的“更好的方式”。你知道，这有点，
there's enough work to do besides that. Well, I mean, assumably they're writing that stuff from scratch, right? Everything in the std colon colon ranges namespace. Oh, in std ranges? Yeah, well, maybe. right everything in the stood colon colon ranges namespace oh instead ranges yeah well maybe well when I say I should clarify when I say ranges I mean the the C++ 20 range version of the yeah the so-called constrained algorithms yes yes I would yeah okay so I would expect I would expect that those do use the concepts, yeah.
除了那个之外还有足够的工作要做。嗯，我是说，假设他们是从零开始编写那些东西，对吧？std::ranges 命名空间中的所有内容。哦，在 std ranges 里？是的，好吧，也许。对 std::ranges 命名空间中的所有内容。哦，在 std ranges 里？是的，好吧，也许。嗯，当我说，我应该澄清，当我说 ranges 时，我指的是 C++ 20 range 版本的，是的，所谓的受约束算法。是的，是的，我会，是的，好的，所以我期望，我会期望那些确实使用了概念，是的。
But I don't know how much synergy there is between those algorithms and the existing iterator algorithms. There might be some underlying common things that both use. Yeah, I'll have to go look. Stay tuned, listener. If I remember to, which I probably will when I'm editing this, I will go and take a look at the C++. Or you know what? I'm sure there's at least one library implementer,
但我不知道这些算法与现有的迭代器算法之间有多少协同作用。可能有一些两者都使用的底层通用东西。是的，我得去看看。敬请期待，听众。如果我记得的话，我编辑的时候可能会记得，我会去看看 C++。或者你知道吗？我相信至少有一个库实现者，
either working on GCC, MSVC, or I mean, there's also folks at NVIDIA. And I know David, who works on the MVC++ compiler. I know he listens, or at least at one point was listening to this podcast. He probably has the answer as well. So feel free to on social media or privately DM me with the answer.
要么在 GCC、MSVC 工作，或者我是说，NVIDIA 也有人。我知道 David，他在 MVC++ 编译器工作。我知道他听，或者至少在某个时候听过这个播客。他可能也有答案。所以请随时在社交媒体上或私下 DM 我答案。
And if not, if I don't get a DM or a public tweet or post, I will go look myself. Anyways, we should get back to the multi-transform. So what is, is your current solution that you just have random access and you're working with arrays so you have a solution for your specific kind of narrow? Yeah, I coded something up. Well, I've been thinking about this a while and it's not been a high priority in my day job so I haven't really done much about it, but I coded something up last night.
如果没有，如果我没有收到 DM 或公开推文或帖子，我会自己去查。总之，我们应该回到 multi-transform。所以，你目前的解决方案是你只有随机访问，而且你在处理数组，所以你针对你那种狭窄的特定情况有一个解决方案？是的，我写了一些东西。嗯，我思考这个问题有一段时间了，这不是我日常工作中的高优先级事项，所以我没有真正做太多，但我昨晚写了一些东西。
And so the interesting another interesting thing that's random mix here is that I already have a variadic version of for each and for each n right so what that means is that basically it's like a zipping together multiple ranges with a for each and so the for for each the the signature looks like taking an iterator pair and then an n-ary function and then the remainder the remaining begin iterators. Really? I was going to assume that. So for each in the standard takes iterator pair and function, right? Unary function. The interesting part is what it returns. It returns the function that you give it or the function object, right?
所以这里随机混合的另一个有趣的事情是，我已经有了 for each 和 for each n 的变长版本，所以这意味着它基本上就像用 for each 将多个范围压缩在一起，所以对于 for each，签名看起来像是接受一个迭代器对，然后是一个 n 元函数，然后是剩余的，剩余的 begin 迭代器。真的吗？我本来会假设那样的。所以标准库中的 for each 接受迭代器对和函数，对吧？一元函数。有趣的部分是它返回什么。它返回你给它的函数或函数对象，对吧？
Because you could pass it a mutable lambda, which has, or something similar that has state. And so it returns the lambda you give it or the function object that you've given it. Okay, actually, I've got a really stupid question that I actually, it's okay that I have forgotten how foreach works because I hate foreach. And I mean, I think Bryce and I had that whole argument of transform versus foreach and the naming at one point where for 30 or 40 minutes, we just refused to agree on the naming of something. Just because you said that your for each implementation takes an n-ary object. Does for each take like the one in the standard take a unary function?
因为你可以传给它一个可变的 lambda，或者类似的东西，它有状态。所以它返回你给它的 lambda 或你给它的函数对象。好的，其实我有一个非常愚蠢的问题，我其实，我忘记了 foreach 是如何工作的，这没关系，因为我讨厌 foreach。我是说，我想 Bryce 和我曾经有过关于 transform 与 foreach 以及命名的争论，有一次我们争论了 30 或 40 分钟，就是拒绝在某事的命名上达成一致。仅仅因为你说你的 for each 实现接受一个 n 元对象。for each 是否像标准库中的那样接受一个一元函数？
Yeah, yeah. Does it? So what's the difference between 4H? I thought so in my head when you were saying that it just takes the iterators and then you apply some operation in the body Oh, no, it has to because it's an algorithm. Yeah, the idea of 4-h is that you're just doing something for side effects Right. So you're doing IO or something. That's the kind of primary use case. You're not really transforming I mean you could view as a transform except that the output iterator would write right something that does IO that you write to right? It doesn't write back to the iterator. Right. So there's no output iterator.
是的，是的。是吗？那么 4H 有什么区别？我以为在我的脑海里，当你那样说时，它只是接受迭代器，然后你在主体中应用某种操作。哦，不，它必须，因为它是一个算法。是的，4-h 的想法是你只是为了副作用而做某事，对吧？所以你在做 IO 或其他什么。那是主要的使用场景。你并不是真的在转换，我是说你可以看作是一个转换，除了输出迭代器会写，对吧？做 IO 的东西你写进去，对吧？它不会写回迭代器。对。所以没有输出迭代器。
Okay. Okay. We're back on the same page. And so you're saying that your API is that you put the begin and end pair of your first range, then the n-ary object, then the... Then the n minus 1 begin iterators in a pack for the underscore N version. Where does the integer go for the end version? The size goes in place of the last iterator. Right. The end iterator. Right. Right.
好的。好的。我们回到同一页了。所以你是说你的 API 是你放入第一个范围的 begin 和 end 对，然后是 n 元对象，然后是……然后是 _N 版本中包里的 n-1 个 begin 迭代器。对于 _N 版本，整数放在哪里？大小放在最后一个迭代器的位置。对。结束迭代器。对。对。
And this is an unfortunate API in my opinion unfortunate because with very addicts you have to always put the very addict stuff at the end. So a lot of the times Yeah, it's kind of constrained by what I can do. Yeah, okay, so that's the API but it nevertheless it's useful it's also unfortunate because we don't get to provide the The end iterators for every range So it's assumed that all the ranges at least cover So it's assumed that all the ranges at least cover that first range or at least as long as that Because if they're not you're in undefined behavior territory. You're running off the end of a rain. Yeah. Yeah, that makes sense
在我看来，这是一个不幸的 API，不幸是因为使用变长参数，你必须总是把变长参数放在最后。所以很多时候，是的，它有点受限于我能做的事情。是的，好的，这就是 API，但它仍然很有用，它也很不幸，因为我们不能提供每个范围的结束迭代器。所以假设所有的范围至少覆盖，所以假设所有的范围至少覆盖那个第一个范围，或者至少和它一样长。因为如果它们不是，你就处于未定义行为的领域。你跑出了范围的末尾。是的。是的，这很有道理。
Okay, so I've totally lost track when you started talking about this and then I got confused by for each Were you saying that you use one of these two? Okay, so I already have variadic for each and variadic for each n. Okay, now the interesting part about those is what they return. For each in the standard, like I said, returns the function object you give it because you might give it something stateful which evolves over the course of the for each. And so it returns that. It does not, however, and the standard for each you just give it the
好的，所以当你开始谈论这个时，我完全失去了头绪，然后我被 for each 搞糊涂了。你是说你使用这两个中的一个吗？好的，所以我已经有了变长 for each 和变长 for each n。好的，现在关于它们有趣的部分是它们返回什么。标准库中的 for each，就像我说的，返回你给它的函数对象，因为你可能会给它一些有状态的东西，它在 for each 的过程中会演变。所以它返回那个。然而，它没有，标准 for each 你只是给它迭代器对，对吧，但每当你谈论 n 版本时，比如 for each n 或 transform n 或任何它可能是的地方，它们接受迭代器和大小，那么你就进入了领域，好吧，如果它是前向迭代器甚至输入迭代器，那么你想要返回，或者甚至可能是双向迭代器，对吧？如果它不是随机访问迭代器，你可能想要返回它被 n 步进后的迭代器，对吧？因为那需要调用者付出努力来恢复。在某些情况下，在输入迭代器的情况下，调用者是不可能恢复的。所以你进入了返回元组的世界。你返回多个东西。你返回，对于变长情况，
iterator pair right, but whenever you're talking about the n versions like for each n or transform n or whatever it might be where they take iterator and size then you're entering the realm of well if it's an forward iterator or even an input iterator, then you want to return or even perhaps a bidirectional iterator, right? If it's not a random x iterator, you probably want to return the iterator as it is after you've stepped it by n, right? Because that would take work for the caller to recover. And in some cases would be impossible for the recall to recover in the input iterate case. So you enter the world of returning a tuple of things. You're returning multiple things. You're returning, for the variadic case,
你返回 n 个输入迭代器和函数对象，它本身可能已经演变了。好的，这很有道理。对吧？有用返回定律决定了这一点。除非你返回它们，否则这些东西调用者无法恢复。对吧。
you're returning n input iterators and the function object, which itself has potentially evolved. OK, that makes sense. Right? The law of useful return sort of dictates this. These things cannot be recovered by the caller unless you return them. Right.
所以，带着这个想法，我正在考虑 for each but last 算法，对吧，作为 initial、medial、final 的构建块算法。而且我正在从变长的角度考虑它，对吧，作为 initial、medial、final 的构建块算法。而且我正在从变长的角度考虑它，对吧，因为我们可以用一个 n 元函数对象对 n 个范围进行 for each but last。而且我们会在最后一个，嗯，我们会在第一个范围的最后一个元素处停止，而且变长范围被假设至少会到达那个点。对。所以你技术上不会，你不需要让所有的范围有相等的长度，
So, you know, carrying that forward, I'm thinking about the for each but last algorithm, right, as the building block algorithm for the initial, medial, final. And I'm thinking about it in terms of variadic, right, as the building block algorithm for the initial, medial, final. And I'm thinking about it in terms of variadic, right, because we can do for each but last over n ranges with an n-ary function object. And we would stop at the last, well, we'd stop at the last element of the first range and the range, the variadic ranges would be assumed to at least go up to that point. Right. So you technically wouldn't, you don't need to have all your range having equal lengths,
技术上。它们只需要至少。是的，它们需要覆盖空间。对。对。然后返回值有同样的约束。如果我们把这看作是一个可以在前向迭代器甚至输入迭代器上工作的算法，你需要返回它们已经演变到的状态的迭代器。对。再次在一个元组中。是的。同样地，函数对象也是如此，也许。而且所有这些都没有真正考虑，所以不像你和 Bryce 的正常谈话，
technically. They just need to be at minimum. Yeah, they need to cover the space. Right. Right. And then the return values have the same kind of constraints. If we're looking at this as an algorithm that can work on forward iterators or even input iterators, you need to return the iterators in the state they've evolved to. Right. In a tuple once again. Yeah. And likewise likewise the function object, maybe. And all of this is not really considering, so unlike your normal conversation with Bryce,
从技术上讲，它们只需要达到最低要求。是的，它们需要覆盖这个空间。没错。没错。然后返回值也有同样的约束。如果我们把这看作是一个可以在前向迭代器甚至输入迭代器上工作的算法，你需要返回已经演变到相应状态的迭代器。没错。再次以元组的形式。是的。同样地，函数对象也可能如此。而且所有这些都没有真正考虑到，所以不像你和Bryce的正常对话，
we are not considering any parallelism here. We're thinking about this as an algorithm which has to proceed linearly, right? Which indeed for each in the standard is, it has a parallel version, but the parallel version I think returns void, right? Which indeed for each in the standard is it has a parallel version, but the parallel version, I think returns void, right? There's a difference there. Yeah, I honestly had no idea that for each returned anything because why like I said, I've I don't I cannot remember the last time if ever. I mean, I don't check C++ code into production but back when I did, I don't know if I ever used a foreach because I was like philosophically opposed to it. And that's a fine argument, right?
我们这里没有考虑任何并行性。我们将其视为一个必须线性执行的算法，对吧？标准库中的 for_each 确实有一个并行版本，但我认为并行版本返回的是 void，对吧？这其中是有区别的。是的，老实说，我根本不知道 for_each 会返回任何东西，因为正如我所说，我不记得上次使用它是什么时候了，如果我曾经用过的话。我的意思是，我不把 C++ 代码提交到生产环境，但回想我还在做的时候，我不知道自己是否用过 foreach，因为我在哲学上反对它。这是一个合理的论点，对吧？
Again, foreach is like the lowest common denominator. It's kind of like, you can do everything with foreach. Just like you can do everything with the raw loop. Right. But, and most of the time, a lot of the time if you're transforming data, of course, you want to use transform or accumulate or reduce or whatever. There's usually some better way of expressing what you want to do. But sometimes you do really want to do for each and it is the best way to express
再说一次，foreach 就像是最低公分母。它有点像，你可以用 foreach 做任何事情。就像你可以用原始循环做任何事情一样。对吧。但是，大多数时候，如果你在转换数据，当然，你会想使用 transform、accumulate 或 reduce 等等。通常有更好的方式来表达你想做的事情。但有时你确实想用 foreach，而且它是表达你想做的事情的最佳方式
that you just want to print all these things out or whatever it might be. Some typically some kind of IO and in my world of embedded 90% of everything is IO. So yeah, I guess back when I was checking C++ into production, I was working on like the core calculation actuarial stuff. And the UI all the time was basically a spreadsheet that the systems engineers, they were doing all the scaffolding there.
比如你只是想把所有这些东西打印出来，或者其他什么。通常是一些 IO 操作，而在我的嵌入式领域，90% 的工作都是 IO。所以是的，我想当我还在把 C++ 代码提交到生产环境时，我是在做核心计算和精算相关的工作。而 UI 部分基本上是一个电子表格，系统工程师们在做那里的脚手架工作。
So really, I had to put stuff in some multi-dimensional array of results. And then it showed up on the screen. I didn't need to worry about that. So I didn't really have like a use case where I needed to do some side effectful thing. And if I was actually doing that in a calculation, odds are that I'm not thinking about it hard enough, right? Because it's one of my favorite quotes is that like imperative shell functional core. And I was always working in the functional
所以实际上，我只需要把东西放进某个多维结果数组中。然后它就会显示在屏幕上。我不需要担心那个。所以我真的没有那种需要做副作用操作的用例。如果我真的在计算中那样做，很可能是我思考得不够深入，对吧？因为我最喜欢的名言之一就是“命令式外壳，函数式核心”。而我一直是在函数式
core part. So odds are, you know, I shouldn't need to reach for for each in those situations. But in your case, where, you know, you are the person doing that system scaffolding to write to somewhere, you know, that that is that is the imperative shell part where you're going to reaching for that all the time. Right. Interesting. Well, I mean, we've you've now got a captive audience. So I mean mean, it used to just be Tristan and Brendal. It used to be Tristan and I, but if folks out on the interwebs have thoughts and comments, feel free to reach out to Ben and maybe we'll come up with a better name for each but last.
核心部分工作。所以很可能，你知道，在那些情况下我不应该需要用到 foreach。但在你的情况下，你知道，你是那个做系统脚手架以便写入某处的人，你知道，那就是你需要一直用到它的“命令式外壳”部分，对吧。有趣。嗯，我的意思是，你现在有了一群忠实的听众。所以我的意思是，以前只有 Tristan 和我，但如果互联网上的朋友们有想法和评论，请随时联系 Ben，也许我们会为“but last”想出一个更好的名字。
Comment on the show notes on GitHub. Yeah, what is a but last? So there's a knit knit there's but last What does knit what's the mnemonic behind knit? So n it or KNIT I? NIT oh in it sorry yeah in it, so I think it's short for like initial But that's just right. Yes. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. I wonder, I know that um, Pharaoh, although I probably,
在 GitHub 的节目笔记上评论。是的，“but last”是什么意思？所以有 init，有 but last。init 的助记符是什么？是 NIT 还是 KNIT？哦，init，抱歉，是的，init，所以我认为它是 initial 的缩写。但那只是……对吧？是的。是的，是的，这说得通。我很好奇，我知道那个……Pharo，虽然我可能，
I'm not sure also, cause you don't spend much time on the socials anymore. Or maybe this can be um, part two now. We're now on episode 230. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthePodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions.
我不确定，因为你不再花太多时间在社交媒体上了。或者这可以成为第二部分。我们现在是第 230 期节目。请务必在你的播客应用中或访问 ADSPthePodcast.com 查看这些节目笔记，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。
Thanks for listening, we hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti brace There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有愉快的一天。我是反大括号派。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。